النيتو في موقف صعب ايران تعلن موعد
تدخلها في حرب فلسطين واسرائيل فيما الجيش
الاسرائيلي يتراجع عن الاجتياح البري لغزه
ويغلق جميع المناطق على الحدود مع لبنان
تلابيب تقطع علاقتها مع الامم المتحده
الحرب في الشرق الاوسط تصدر الرعب
لاوكرانيا القوه الاسرائيليه تشن حمله
واسعه لاعتقال الفلسطينيين وسائل الاعلام
تعلن العدد الحق حقيه لاسرى اسرائيل لدى
المقاومه تونس تقف بثبات مع فلسطين وترسل
دعمها للفلسطينيين بعد دعمها لاسرائيل
فرنسا تحث على الجانب الانساني السلام
عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته متابعي قناه
شاهد لتعرف في كل مكان انتم تعلمون اننا
كالجميع نشرنا فيديوهات وتقارير عن القضيه
الفلسطينيه وعن الاحداث التي حصلت مؤخرا
بين الكيان والمقاومه ورغم التزامنا بكل
معاير يوتيوب وحرصنا الشديد على ان لا
يكون هناك اي انتهاكات للاسف الشديد مع
ذلك تم تقييد القناه وفرض قيود كبير عليها
ليست قناتنا فقط بل العديد من القنوات
التي تعرضت لمثل هذا من قبل جوجل من قبل
يوتيوب من قبل الاداره الامريكيه لان جوجل
هي شركه امريكيه والغرب يمارس سياسه تكميم
الافوه رغم انه يتشدق دائما بحريه التعبير
والديمقراطيه وما الى ذلك المهم اذا قصتكم
احنا بطلنا احنا ما بطلناش ولا عم نبطل
ولا عم توقف ان شاء الله احنا مستمرين
معكم معنا قناه احتياطيه نطرح لكم الرابط
في الوصف وفي تعليق نتمنى انكم تدعمونا
مثل ما دعمتنا في القناه الاولى شهد لتعرف
نتمنى دعمكم في القناه الثانيه احنا
مستمرين في نشرنا اليومي ان شاء الله كما
عهدتمونا تحياتي تل ابيب تتراجع خلفاء
الطرفين يتحضرون للتدخل في حرب فلسطين
واسرائيل وكل يتحين الوقت المناسب هنا نقل
موقع اكسيوس عن مصادر مطلعه قولها ان
ايران اوضحت لاسرائيل عبر الامم المتحده
انها لا يريد مزيدا من التصعيد في الحرب
على غزه واضاف الموقع ان ايران اوضحت
لاسرائيل ايضا عبر الامم المتحده انه
سيتعين عليها التدخل اذا استمرت الحرب على
غزه ونفذت اسرائيل تهديدها بتنفيذ هجوم
بري هذا الهجوم البري الذي اعلنت عنه تل
ابيب لايام تراجعت عنه مؤخرا حيث نقلت
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز عن مصادر في الجيش
الاسرائيلي انه تم تاجيل العمليه البريه
لبضعه ايام بسبب سوء الطقس الذي قد يعيق
قدره الطيارين ومشغلي الطائرات المسيره
على دعم القوات برايكم هو سبب كاف للتراجع
قد نستطيع الاجابه على السؤال من خلال كشف
صحيفه فلت الالمانيه ان حلف شمال الاطلسي
النيتو يواجه موقفا صعبا وربما لا يملك
الحلف الاموال والمعدات الكافيه لدعم
اوكرانيا واسرائيل في ان واحد لربما يكون
هذا هو سبب التراجع الاسرائيلي اليس كذلك
وليس ليس ذلك فحسبه بل ان الرعب قد وصل
الى اوكرانيا بسبب هذه الحرب حيث قالت
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز ان كيف قلقه من
احتمال تقليل المساعدات الغربيه على خلفيه
الصراع في الشرق الاوسط ليعلن مندوب
اسرائيل الدائم لدى الامم المتحده جلعد
اردان انه قرر قطع العلاقات مع منسق الامم
المتحده الخاص للتسويه في الشرق الاوسط
ترسلان حتى يدين الاخير ايران من جانبه
وبعد اعلان دعمه المطلق لاسرائيل اعلن
الارز في بيان له ان الرئيس الفرنسي
امانويل ماكرون كثف اتصالاته مع الزعماء
الاجانب وحث مصر واسرائيل خصوصا على فتح
ممر انساني الى غزه عبر معبر رفح اما في
اسرائيل فخرج الاسرائيليون بمظاهرات حاشده
امام مقر وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه في تل
ابيب للمطالبه باستعاده الاسرى المحتجزين
في قطاع غزه لدا كتائب القسام وردد ه تفات
مناهضه لرئيس الحكومه بنيامين نتنياهو
وطالبوا برحيله عن السلطه وسجنه حتى ان
جنود اسرائيليين هاجموا نتنياهو خلال
زيارته الى منطقه غلاف غزه الامر الذي ادى
الى الغاء كلمه كان من المقرر ان يلقيها
هناك والان ميدانيا حيث نشر الجيش
الاسرائيلي اسماء سبعه جنود اضافيين قتلوا
خلال الايام الاخيره وعلى ذكر الاعداد في
هذه الحرب افادت قناه ارتي الروسيه بان
التقديرات الاخيره لعدد الاسرائيليين
الاسرى لدى المقاومه في قطاع غزه بلغ
126 بينما ذكرت بعض المصادر الاسرائيليه
في وقت سابق ان عدد الرهائن بلغ
150 بالمقابل نددت هيئه شؤون الاسرى
والمحررين الفلسطينيين بحمله الاعتقالات
التي شنتها القوات الاسرائيليه مؤخرا
اطالت اكثر من 500 فلسطيني في الضفه
الغربيه والقدس هذا واعلن الجيش
الاسرائيلي مقتل جنديه في في قوات البحريه
واصابه سته اخرين خلال مناورات على الجبهه
الشماليه حتى ان الاكران ينفذون بجلوده من
هذه الحرب فقد اعلن المتحدث الرسمي باسم
وزاره الخارجيه الاوكرانيه اوليغ نيكولين
كو عن اقلاع اول رحله اجلاء للمواطنين
الاوكرانيين من تل ابيب بانتظار بقيه
الرحلات بحسب ما ذكرت صحيفه كتري فيما
افادت القناه الثانيه ع الاسرائيليه بتعرض
منزل في مستوطنه ديروت ل اصابه مباشره
بصاروخ اطلق من غزه ولازلنا في اجواء
الحرب لكن بعيدا عن فلسطين حيث افادت
القناه ال 14 الاسرائيليه باطلاق صاروخ من
سوريا نحو الجولان فيما اكدت اذاعه الجيش
الاسرائيلي اعتراض هذا الصاروخ وياتي ذلك
وسط توتر تشهده الحدود السوريه
الاسرائيليه منذ انطلاق عمليه طوفان
الاقصى على الحدود اللبنانيه افادت وسائل
الاعلام بمقتل اسرائيلي واصابه اخرين في
مست وطنه اتوه جراء قصف متبادل على الحدود
الاسرائيليه اللبنانيه هناك اعلن الجيش
الاسرائيلي اغلاق كل المناطق على مسافه عه
كيلومترات من الحدود اللبنانيه وحضر
الحركه فيها عربيا جدد الرئيس التونسي قيس
السعيد التاكيد على ثبات مواقف بلاده
ومبدئي تجاه القضيه الفلسطينيه قائلا لن
نعيش اذله سنعمل على ان تستقل فلسطين هذا
وارسلت تونس طائره محمله المساعدات
الانسانيه الى الشعب الفلسطيني